support move University in the
production of more video tutorials by
making a financial contribution or by
getting yourself one of these t-shirts
details under the support move section
I'll move university comm the link will
be in the description below thank you
and enjoy
okay so general chemistry before we can
study and understand the complexities of
chemistry we really need to know certain
basics including definitions and things
like that so this first series in the G
chem series is about the basics and sort
of things that you need to know in order
to understand chemistry we're going to
start with matter but before we can
really talk about chemistry
we got know you know what is chemistry
simply put chemistry is the study of
matter so what is matter though matter
is anything and everything that has mass
and volume and you might have heard
those terms before but if you haven't
and you don't know what they are
the terms themselves will make more
sense when we discuss how these things
are measured but now why do chemists
care about matter because it matters
chemists care about what things or what
makes things what they are they study
substances which are things that have a
particular composition or a particular
makeup we'll talk more about the
definition of substances and what kind
of classifies or is classified as a
substance we'll talk about that later
but they also study the the properties
the properties of substances and these
properties include both physical and
chemical properties so what is a
physical property and what is a chemical
property well let's start with physical
properties physical properties are
characteristics a substance shows by
itself without changing into some other
substance or interacting with another
substance okay so this is pretty
important one really important part of
this definition is they by itself fit by
itself and without changing those are
important parts so physical properties
are characteristics of a substance that
that substance shows by itself and
wayward and it's not changing into
something else
or interacting with something else or
some other substance so some examples
are color or density boiling point even
melting point color for instance like
water water is a clear it's clear right
when it's a liquid and also in its solid
as well that's that's a physical
property waters density at 25 degrees
Celsius and one atmospheric pressure is
one gram per milliliter
that can vary slightly but the point is
these are physical properties these are
things that these are characteristics of
a substance that are independent of
another substance interacting with this
particular substance I use the word
substance a lot there but hopefully I
can kind of explain this with an example
um well with an example of a physical
change specifically so physical changes
are changes that occur when when the
form of the substance changes not its
makeup or identity so this is when this
is an important part the form changes
not the identity okay so let's think
about the example of freezing liquid
water into solid ice
a lot of people know that h2o is the
chemical formula for water and this
little this little in parenthesis here
is a little cursive L which means liquid
we'll talk more about that later but
water in liquid form can turn into water
in the solid form and that's what
happens when we're taking liquid water
and turning it into solid ice isn't it
still water yeah it's still water
it hasn't changed its identity that is a
physical change so you know water being
a liquid at room temperature and a solid
at really the cold temperature
specifically colder than zero degrees
Celsius or 32 degrees Fahrenheit or 273
Kelvin that is a physical property
whether it's just liquid or solid and
this is a physical change changing from
liquid to solid its identity hasn't
changed it's still water and that's what
I meant by by itself without changing
into some other
substance it's still the same thing okay
now let's talk about chemical properties
chemical properties as you might have
might imagine they're their
characteristics substance shows when
interacting with other substances so
that's that's the important part of this
definition interacting with other
substances or when it's changed that's
also a really important term into some
other substance
so really chemical properties are
basically describe the reactivity of a
certain substance and there there are of
course chemical changes as opposed to
physical changes and chemical changes
chemical changes have another name
really they're called chemical reactions
and so we're talking about when one
substance interact with another
substance and changes to some other
substance doesn't even have to interact
with something necessarily as long as it
changes its substance but I think pretty
much pretty much all the time it's
interacting with something else in fact
I have an example here of a chemical
reaction and if the example is the
combustion of octane which is gasoline
so if you take octane and oxygen and you
put them together you add a little bit
of heat what happens is that we change
these two initial or these two initial
substances that we start with octane and
oxygen we change them into carbon
dioxide and water that's a chemical
reaction so it's a chemical property of
octane which is the chemical four that
is used for gasoline to power our cars
and even lawnmowers and stuff but octane
has a certain level of reactivity with
oxygen and if it is enough heat that can
cause this to basically explode and
create carbon dioxide and water and this
of course this is a reaction that
releases energy which is another thing
I'll talk about later but the point is
that we start off we start off with
octane and oxygen and those things are
changed into carbon dioxide and water we
no longer have octane oxygen so it's a
chemical property
bockting the way react with oxygen next
up the three states of matter so you may
or may not have already known this but
the three states of matter are solid
liquid and gas I think one of the
simplest ways to kind of understand this
is really to just talk about it in terms
of example the simplest example is water
so we know that water can exist as a
solid that we call ice right and of
course you can exist a liquid that we
drink and it can also exist as a gas
which is we call water vapour so I'll
put all those little terms here as well
so here we got ice solid liquid water
and then water vapor is the gas okay so
what are some of the characteristics of
you know solids and liquids guess what
defines them well solids solids have a
fixed shape they have a fixed shape and
volume they have a fixed shape and
volume they do not take the shape of
their container so if you put ice into
like a beaker or a bucket it's only
going to take up as much space as it
takes up as it's it's in it you know in
its ice form it's not going to take the
volume of the container doesn't flow at
all
it's very fixed and definite shape and
volume liquids however liquids they they
kind of flow right they conform to the
shape of their container but it occupies
only its own volume not the volume of
the entire container in the way that a
gas does which we'll get to in just a
second so if you put a liquid into a cup
or a beaker liquid water specifically
and you kind of you know swish around
the the cup the the water will kind of
or the liquid will kind of you know go
back and forth and kind of adhere to the
the shape of the container if you have a
round glass
it'll take the shape of a round class
but it doesn't take the entire volume of
the the container it doesn't take up the
entire space of the container it only
takes up its own volume and kind of
conforms to the the shape of the
container only to a certain extent okay
another thing about liquids is that they
form what's called a surface right so
you can have when you when you once you
know at the top of its you it takes the
volume of its content of its excuse me
it takes the shape of its container to a
certain extent but it does have a
surface that you can kind of clearly see
gases however they they take the entire
shape and volume of their containers
they fill the entire container so if you
have a small cup and you you know have
it shut and you initially have some
liquid in there some liquid water and
you boil it it all becomes gaseous water
vapor and that water vapor will take up
the entire volume of the container and
it of course takes the shape as well
because it fills the entire the entire
space of its container and of course
because of this it'll have no surface so
these are just some details I don't want
to go into too many because this is just
a video about the basics but I hope that
video is helpful thank you for watching
if you found that video helpful be sure
to fiddle with the like and don't forget
to subscribe if you haven't already also
be sure to share the video with anyone
you think might find it helpful thanks
and happy studying